I thought it might be helpful to go
through very quickly. Three of the major,
uh, processes of deriving chemicals
from petroleum feed stocks.
So the first feed stock I
wanted to look at is methane.
So natural gas,
this is what's even before fracking.
This has been a major source of
chemicals in the United States.
And so the process is here.
Um,
don't have to worry about
every one of these arrows,
but if you look at the
things that are coming out,
so at the top you have methane
is coming in. So natural gas,
there's also something called a
natural gas liquids that often contains
propylene.
Propylene is,
yeah,
it's a three carbon molecule.
So those are the two major inputs.
And then we can look at
the things that come out.
So hydrogen gas is a very
important synthetic building block.
Um, ammonia and urea, you
can say, well, wait a minute,
that that's not in natural gas.
So we're adding nitrogen atoms
are being introduced here.
And why would we be producing
so much ammonia and urea?
What's that going to get used for? Yeah,
fertilizers. So basically ever, I mean,
some very large percentage of our biome,
our body mass is based on nitrogen
that comes out of these processes. Um,
methanol is one of the largest use
solvents to scenic acid formaldehyde.
A couple of interesting compounds
over here. I, so Butyraldehyde uh,
another unusual chemical, it kind of pops
up here is to Ethel [inaudible] acid.
Does anybody have any
idea what that's used for?
So it has to do with plastics.
Um,
most of the PVC plastic that gets used,
uh,
needs plasticizers to make
it soft or flexible. Yes.
So this is being fed directly
into plasticizer use.
What kind of summarize a slide
then? So we're, we're taking these,
these one carbon three carbon feedstocks
and we're making fertilizers by
introducing nitrogen, making
solvents, making plasticizers.
And if you look at the molecular
structures of these compounds,
they are also one carbon two co carbon
and we're starting to build up to higher
carbon numbers here, right? So, uh,
even, uh, to Ethel Hex, no luck acid,
that's c eight compounds.
And then looking at the Olefin processes.
So this is an even more con, uh,
complicated flow diagram. But again,
let's look at the things that we're
going in here. So raw materials, uh,
there's some salt is going in
that's kind of interesting,
right?
So it's sodium chloride,
there's oxygen is coming in
and very large amounts. Uh,
naphtha is one of the oil
fractions. And then, uh,
there's basically cuts of all Finnick
of hydrocarbons that are coming directly
from crude oil.
And so what's coming out here I think
should be a lot of recognizable chemicals.
So caustic soda. Uh, how about vinyl
chloride? What does that get used for?
Does that ring any bells?
Yeah, PVC plastic. So, uh,
we can start filling in kind
of our recycling triangles.
So there's a PVC is our number three.
Uh,
how about HDPE? Ldpe people know what
those are. What does the P stand for Paul?
We have families, so we've got number
one and two. Um, ethylene oxide,
it's actually used directly in a
lot of shipping. So when people, uh,
transport produce around the world,
they fill the shipping containers with
ethylene oxide gas, it's extremely toxic.
So it's supposed to keep, you know,
prevent biological contamination,
prevent mold growth, prevent other
organisms. For getting into it,
but it's also extremely toxic to
people and it's a highly explosive.
And when we get into
the accidents lecture,
we'll see that a lot of the US
chemical safety board videos,
unfortunately I have been dealing with
ethylene oxide explosions and it can do
an awful lot of damage. A
FNOL and acetone. We'll, we'll
come back to in a second.
Here's a styrene that should
be a pretty easy one, right?
So polystyrene and we just
got our number six. Um,
spr is a styrene butadiene rubber
that's basically synthetic rubber.
So whenever anybody talks about rubber
and it's not coming from the tree,
that's basically what it is. And
then Polly ice supreme. What,
what does polyisoprene get used for?
It's a tire is basically,
so the number one use of polyisoprene
is going into tire manufacturing.
I guess I should have added the propylene.
So we're making poly polypropylene,
so we've got, or one,
two, three, four, five,
six recycling triangles already.
And then number seven,
we'll cover poly lactic acid.
So that,
that's basically it already we've got
all of our major plastics out of the two
first petroleum cuts.
We've looked at and then I wanted to
come back to these funnel and acetone
points here cause this,
this helps further illustrate a point
that professor and assets was just making.
So this is bisphenol a, we were just
talking about the phosgene. That's,
this is the other chemical that goes
into reaction with phosgene to make
polycarbonate gets used in epoxy resins.
And this is when it comes from, it comes
from funnel and it comes from Acetone.
And kind of the philosophical question
here is do people use it because it's the
best performing chemical
in this application?
I mean we said in the very beginning
of class, if there's something like,
I don't know, 44 million,
48 million known chemicals,
what are the chances that this one that's
two steps away from raw olefins are
going to be the,
this is going to be the best performing
chemical for a given application.
It's often not the best performing
chemical, but it's just so cheap.
It's so available because it's right at
the beginning the chemical food chain,
so to speak. And so one of the
strategies that we'll see for, um,
biobased chemicals is to try and
come up with something similar.
If you can get something that's just one
or two steps away from sugar or Chitin
or you know, switch grass, then maybe
you have this same kind of advantage.
And so the last major petroleum based cut
that I wanted to talk about is the nap
one, not the, uh,
is mainly used to derive what's
called Btx, the benzene, toluene,
xylenes. And so looking at the
things that come out of this, again,
um, benzine is a useful product and
its own right styrene. So, um, again,
the polystyrene plastic,
uh,
Phallic and hydride is the other piece
of the plasticizers that we were just
talking about.
So that's the Thal late part of the
pathologic is the valid part of those
plasticizers.
And then last thing that comes
out here is dimethyl tariff alley.